all right guys
bang bang i've got aj here thanks for
doing this man
yeah absolutely thanks for having me for
sure uh let's just jump right in uh
let's talk about your background
um and kind of what you did before uh
vaynermedia and then vaynersports that
you're running today
sure um i mean it starts with
being born in jersey um grew up in a
small town in new jersey kind of on the
border of pennsylvania and
nj um grew up in a household
uh i'm first generation my family's from
belarus
my parents were born there my brother
was born there my sister and i born here
in america
um so you know grew up in a very
interesting household one that blended
two cultures
um but then one also that was very
centered around entrepreneurship
uh my father's an entrepreneur came to
this country
did a lot of things to make ends meet
but ultimately landed on the idea
and grew into owning his own wine retail
shop
and so um entrepreneurship was the
driving conversation at the dinner table
and it was interesting because
uh gary's 11 years older than i am and
so because of that
um the fact that it was kind of where my
dad had a lot of his focus ended up
being where my brother had a lot of
focus
um you know 10 11 12 13 in the dinner
table conversations business
and i'm very lucky for that and that was
huge for me and
i uh i was also pretty good with math
and naturally inclined with math so
business wasn't a huge leap from me um
and you know grew up with that i went to
school in boston went to boston
university
um met my wife there and
you know spent spent most of my college
career
trying to figure out what i wanted to do
uh business-wise
and it was essentially unrelated to what
i was studying in school
i ended up working out i majored in
advertising and minor to computer
science
um which is a really interesting mix um
i don't recommend minoring in computer
science if you're going to take computer
science you should probably major in it
i remember i'll never forget i was like
uh a junior
and one of my professors i mean like
comp sci
242 whatever it is right one of the
professors like so like you learned last
year in cs 212 and cs230
and i didn't take cs212 and 230 right
and so that was
super tough but i figured it out i'm
glad i did it um
and uh but i really spent most of it
just trying to figure out what i wanted
to do from an entrepreneurship
standpoint i always knew
gary and i always knew we wanted to do
something together and so my senior year
was really focused on honing that in
we had a few different ideas you know
for timing this is around 2008 2009 so
not a great time from an economic
standpoint in our country and um
we toyed around with like a fantasy
baseball
concept we toyed around with the deal of
the day
type concept um but where we ultimately
landed
was vaynermedia and and the reason we
landed on that was because
gary was already doing so much for his
personal brand
utilizing things like twitter and
facebook that
he started having um people in his
network saying hey
you're doing this for yourself can you
help me do this for a business
and you know we saw it as an opportunity
to take something that we were
interested in you know social media
platforms
i actually spent a summer in san
francisco uh in between my junior and
senior year at a company called
revision3 which was a sister company to
dig
at the time and so we just had our hands
of silicon
um valley and tech startups and what i
guess was called web 2.0 at the time
and then also um through
gary's own network just being in
business you know he's in his early 30s
at this point
um we had relationships with corporate
america and a little bit of luck came
from the fact that uh
without knowing it prior new jersey is
actually a very big epicenter for
corporate hqs uh specifically around
consumer packaged goods
so you have a lot of big cpg companies
that are in jersey and a lot of those
big cpg company executives
happen to be customers of the wine
library and personal relationships of my
brother and so
we just saw it as kind of like
opportunistic it felt
right given just the economic situation
and we also had so much belief in these
platforms and how they were working for
my brother
that we knew brands would latch on and
so we felt like we were ahead of the
pack
nobody was really doing it at scale and
we jumped on it and that's how
vaynermedia really got going
yeah and so what's really interesting is
uh you obviously have the
um school background right when it comes
to advertising computer science like
what you guys ended up building there is
like
almost dead on to that but it sounds
like you didn't actually know
that's what you were going to go do
right so talk a little bit just about
um you know obviously you're in a
situation where your brother
10 years older he had the relationships
right he was kind of really out there
you've obviously kind of taken a
different path where you're like look
that's great for my brother but maybe
not something that i necessarily want to
go do
but you guys end up working together and
so a lot of people don't have you know
a brother whether that's you know either
way in terms of a complimentary skill
set
but how did you guys really ideate to
that point was it just like a customer
came and said hey i really want you guys
to do this i'll be the first customer
or was it something where you eventually
hey we should do the media side
and let's go try to find some of the
early customers it was it was more so
the former
um you know at that point so i guess
it's like 2006
uh my brother 2006 or 2007 my brother
starts creating something called wine
library tv
where he's doing video blogs tasting
wine and builds up a real audience from
it and it's going really well
um and it's just doing really well big
audience big numbers
um and then from that he decided to
expand on his content creation which you
know now
knowing what he's doing now that adds up
right and so he starts
garyvaynerchuk.com so it launches a
personal website
and the website is basically
a video blog centered around business
comma
social media and the intersection of
social media and business so he does
that
that starts doing really well he then
starts getting asked to do speaking gigs
um and so he starts you know primarily
in the new york new jersey area and then
eventually across the country
and this is really 2008 2009 so he's
starting to speak at events
and what started happening was a few
months before i would graduate college
he just had a few executives from a few
major brands come up to him say hey
loved what you talked about on stage can
we expand on that can we bring you in
for a four-hour brainstorm with our
marketing team can we bring you in
so he does one of those where he flies
uh to a fortune 500
gets in the room with a few c-suites uh
executives
does like a four-hour brainstorm and
then the brainstorm
they're like that was awesome how do we
actually go do what you just said
and that's where my brother you know
he's not he's not the one that's going
to create the deck
or write up an outline word document
plan and that's where he's like hey
i think i can bring in the interest kind
of like the um
indirect sales funnel i can start with
the big ideas and set the strategy
but i think i need infrastructure built
out to actually create the documentation
and the structure that a corporate brand
would want
i feel like that's you're you know you
were good at school you're good at this
type of stuff
like my brother was a terrible student i
was a good student the one thing we
shared is we both hated school
but i just sucked it up and was good at
it and so um
that's really how it came to be it was
just kind of like
this natural synergy that just came to
be and
we saw it as an opportunity to get a
profitable business off the ground right
away i mean we were profitable on day
one with the media company
yeah and so obviously uh he
being out there and you not being out
there and so much on the social content
side
everyone kind of looks at like they saw
the journey if you will if they've been
paying attention long enough because
they just saw hey he was talking at you
know
uh a thing a video on youtube that has
200 people now there's 500 people now
there's 2 000 people right
i can watch his followers grow whatever
but this entire time
you're basically running the operations
of a business that
for those people that don't know is very
large and ended up growing to
you know hundreds of people and so talk
a little bit about
just that experience for you uh you know
you were young in your career right but
but kind of
thrown in the fire with a great
opportunity yes there's revenue you're
profitable on day one
but like you don't just get the magic
pill of like oh next thing we know we've
got 500 employees in a really big
business right like there's a lot of
kind of steps in between so let me talk
a little bit just about like once you
guys said all right let's go do this
how did you think about scaling the team
building it out learning what you didn't
know and ultimately kind of building
vayner into what it is today
yeah i think um
i think a lot of it came you know i was
22
when we started it right and by the time
i was 24
i was the ceo of a 150 person eight
figure company right
and and a very traditional one not like
a tech startup right where that that
makes sense
right that you know if somebody was
super young and came up with this
innovative social app or something this
was
a very traditional like i would show up
to the board room with
50 60 plus men and women you know year
old men and women
who expected not the tech you know
startup founder
i think so much of it worked out um
from just preparation in the sense that
and a lot of luck and you know i would
have never
been able to be in the situation i was
if my brother wasn't 10 years older
successful already had a network right
like my business career
started on third base um but
what i think helped me be confident and
comfortable in the role at such a young
age
was um i was living breathing and
thinking business
all throughout middle school and high
school like and it's a similar story to
my brothers right my brother did it
primarily through baseball cards in high
school
i did it primarily through garage sales
yard sales thrift stores and ebay
i mean i was a eighth grader and i would
come home from school
and i would literally walk into my
bedroom which was 30
8th grader bedroom 70 uh warehouse
logistics factory
my room was filled with packaging
materials random assortments of junk
my computer setup printer scanner etc i
literally come home
first thing i would do is ship out that
day's orders because i had 30 or 40 ebay
auctions and the night before and
i did all sorts of things like i created
my own like um
i had a spreadsheet and a database and i
had basically i gave everything a
invoice number and serial number i had
envelopes organized by number
by category and i would come home and i
would pull product off the shelves
in this bedroom and i would package it
all up and then i would have to ask my
mom to drive me to the post office
because i grew up in a very rural area
and then my mom would take me for like
the eight-minute drive to the post
office and
i would see the post office uh men and
women there and
the postal workers and it was every day
this little kid coming in
not only was i like in seventh and
eighth grade but i looked like i was in
fourth or fifth grade
always looked i was always small and
young looking
and so come in with 40 50 30 20 packages
every single day and so i did a lot of
that i learned a lot about just
research logistics organization
customer service all those types of
things
and then you know i did that and really
did well
like was making real money as like a kid
and then in college i
i built websites and i was mainly
building and launching blogs and
i taught myself um you know web design
you know photoshop and uh css and html
and primarily relied on wordpress
and then you know was taking computer
science so i was learning a few other
things that i could do a little bit more
advanced work with like php aspects of
wordpress
you know never to the point where i was
building anything
beyond building on top of existing
platforms like wordpress but
it was enough and i was building
websites and i was signing up local
businesses in massachusetts to build
their website and
improve their seo or get their adwords
running and
buying domains like was just dabbling
and being super entrepreneurial
um and then gary and i landed on doing
the business and we got it up and
running and
i think the other thing too is for as
public
of a front man my brother is i think
because he's so good at that and is so
well known for that
he's become actually underrated as an
operator
um you know my brother operated and grew
a business my father's business from 4
to 60 million
without any public brand or presence
that's from operations right and so
um i always had my business partner you
know i was it was very good that we were
11 years apart because it was very clear
he was the ceo and i was a ceo it helped
that he was one and i was two
and you know having your business
partner and brother also be your mentor
um helped me tremendously through those
times
i've got four younger brothers and i
always tell them like i trust other
people
but there's just something about your
brother right like
you can think back to when you guys were
fighting as kids you know in your living
room all the way to
all the good times as well and you just
for whatever reason you trust them
right absolutely yeah it makes sense um
and so talk a little bit about
uh at some point you decide hey i'm
really passionate about sports i'm gonna
go off and start vayner sports
what was kind of the impetus there did
you always want to go do that or was
that something that kind of grew over
time
and then how did you guys actually get
that started yeah i grew up
being very interested in the
intersection of business sports
um i was in high school and
die hard sports fan um unfortunately for
me jets and nicks are my two primary
teams and it's been
as a 33 year old it hasn't been the
greatest run jet's been better than the
knicks but
i kind of missed the glory knicks i was
i i was there but i was too young for
those early 90s teams you know
being five six seven eight i remember it
but i didn't really live it
um so i was always a big sports fan and
then just like
my two biggest passions are business and
sports and so the sports business side
is that intersection
um so for example i loved the nfl draft
growing up loved i went all in and would
learn all the college football players
and try to
you know do mock drafts and read all the
mock drafts and try to understand
what makes the good teams good what do
they do in the draft what are some of
their philosophies how do they differ
from the other teams
you know another aspect is i was always
interested in the salary cap and the
management of the team
i think um you know as a jets fan there
was some
really interesting the jets had a track
record and still do frankly
of having a lot of their young drafted
stars end up
out of there so you know um keyshawn
johnson when i was really little
you know was 9 10 11 12. he he forced
his way out
john abraham was another one darrell
reavis when i got older
most recently jamal adams right and so
the jets always had that kind of history
for whatever reason and so being a jets
fan i was always interested in that
aspect what
what led to keyshawn getting traded and
why was he traded for what he ended up
getting traded for and stuff like that
and then even like madden i would play a
ton of madden but i would play franchise
mode more than i would actually play the
actual game because i liked
the roster construction and trades and
salary cap and the draft and all that
and so i grew up liking it um
how we ended up getting there was um
we along the way so i was
i ran vaynermedia with gary from 09 to
16.
um we did a lot of angel investing along
the way and had some really good success
with that and one of our smaller
investments later on
in that 2015-2016 time period was a
small boutique sports agency
and we did it more for fun than anything
it was a small check for both of us and
you know agencies don't have the biggest
multiples don't have the biggest upside
but we just were genuinely interested in
the space and we thought it was fine and
so we got involved
and when i ended up leaving the media
company
looking for a new challenge i originally
left with no plan and that was important
to me
i was always the kid that had a plan i
got in early to boston university
vaynermedia started before i even
graduated from boston university
um so i was always somebody that knew
what the next step was and i just like
you know what i don't want to know the
next step i kind of want to let it go i
want to take a little bit of time
but soon into my time off my original
plan was to take a year off
um two months in you know
i loved you know i loved all the free
time i loved shedding the responsibility
at the time i didn't have kids all i had
was a you know a girlfriend and a dog
um but um you know
there's only so much golf that could be
played and only so much dog walking
and things like that and so i i started
kind of going into the portfolio
and just catching up with companies and
after like another month or two i
realized that
i probably had between my own personal
investments in the fund that we did
there's probably like 80 companies that
were active
and i found myself gravitating to the
sports agency even though
objectively it probably had the lowest
upside
and and that's all i really needed to
know uh you know and i thought that
um from having previous experience with
a few athletes along the way primarily
on the investing side
and a little bit on the vaynermedia
brand side um and then just looking
at the current agency that we were
investors in and then just reading like
the industry rag
and kind of immersing myself in the
culture of athlete rep
i just felt like we had an opportunity
to bring a differentiated offering
which is important to me i don't want to
do anything if i don't think i can do it
better and different
um and i also thought that i could take
my experience building vaynermedia
and really apply it strongly to vayner
sports because at the end of the day
even though the clients are very
different there's a very big difference
between like a pepsi
and a leonard williams um it's still
client services
and so um yeah that's what led to it
and so what was the differentiation
right so i think
many people don't even understand like
how a sports agency works so maybe just
kind of go through like
hey here's the the business of a sports
agency here's how they make money and
then when you guys stepped in
um kind of what was your pitch to uh you
know really the athletes
in terms of here's what we are going to
do different or better than everybody
else
yeah so it and i'll speak to football
specifically
even though we've expanded in numerous
sports i can i think i illustrate this
best just talking about football
um the typical
football the most commonly represented
type of football agency
is kind of the equivalent of your
accountant
it's very much a professional service
that's provided
um it is a situation where the vast
majority of those providers have a very
narrow
point of view and level of expertise and
so what ends up happening
is um the relationship is transactional
so one of the biggest things that i saw
that is the most common theme throughout
the industry is that
the agent and the player only have a
relationship as long as that player is
still providing commission to the agent
so if a player
goes pro signs with an agent and falls
flat on their face
you will find countless stories of the
agent just stopping
stop picking up the call they don't pick
up the call um
if a player retires even if they have a
very good career
there's no longer commission checks
coming the professional services of the
agent is done
it's over um and so you know you have
that
within the industry you also commonly
have a second
offering um that is separate from the
contract advisor slash agent which is
centered around marketing and pr
um so you have marketing agents p you
know publicist etc so that exists
um that also operates where it's like
hey i'm you know the marketing agent or
the publicist is either on retainer or
on a commission basis
if you're not driving uh revenue you're
not being serviced just like an
accountant or a lawyer right
and so we came in and we looked at that
and we said okay we have a background in
marketing
we have an interest in this contract
representation side which basically
requires
you know negotiation experience and
things of that nature we're gonna come
in and combine the two
and that concept isn't novel there are
other players that do it
but what is novel is doing that concept
well
um there are we have competitors that
provide both contract and marketing
but when i looked at it four years ago
there wasn't a single player in the
space
um that was doing it on an a level and i
thought that we could and then the last
piece um
is the fact that even beyond that
we're adding this third layer of
entrepreneurship business personal
branding investing right basically
my background my brother's background
and we're integrating that in a world
where i feel as if
athletes are craving that more and more
every single day every single month
every single year
and so that that stem from um you know
like i said we had some exposure to
athletes and we're you know was
fortunate enough to
you know share dinner conversations with
guys like draymond green carmelo anthony
et cetera
entirely from the lens of investing
right but
talking to them and learning more about
how they're moving and
how their agent does and doesn't play a
role really
opened my eyes that there was a gap to
fill and
i just don't think that athletes 10 to
15 years ago
were seeking the same type of service as
they are today and so we just thought
that
the entire industry was servicing
athletes as these one-dimensional
um commission makers and we just felt
that athletes
um are just getting smarter and smarter
and want to do more and more
and are broadening their horizons and we
thought we could support that
so there's a lot of people who've come
onto the podcast and various
conversations talked about this idea of
kind of an evolution so whether it's an
athlete a creator whoever
right basically it's like you do what
you do so if you're an athlete you play
a sport if you're a creator you create
content
then eventually it got to the point
where maybe i don't want to take the
advertising dollars of a sponsorship
maybe i'll just take like half an
equity right so i'll earn equity uh
eventually that became okay maybe i
should actually put money forward and
invest
now what we're starting to see i think
is more and more
um you know creators and athletes and
people just with audience say wait a
second maybe i actually should like
start a company right and how do i go
partner up with an operator
uh and then i think kind of like the end
goal for some of these people is like
this holding company right where you can
invest you can own assets you can kind
of do a whole bunch of different things
and you know people will debate where we
are along that journey but that just
kind of feels like the trend
absolutely it feels like you guys saw
that early and stepped in and said look
we can help you negotiate your contract
but that's kind of the table stakes
of what you're trying to do it's less of
like an
athlete manager or sports manager and
it's more of like a business
confidant or a business partner to some
degree is that fair to kind of to
categorize it no i think that is fair
and you know something i touched upon
in that prior topic we just talked about
um
that speaks to this is partnership
and the fact that when our clients are
done playing
our job is not done so um you know we're
a young agency so we only have so many
players that are done playing you know
but
um you know guys that have you know
finished their careers
we're still involved in their lives
we're still partners and advisors in the
things that they want to do and i think
it speaks to that point where
when we sign a client to vaynersports
the idea is that
yes we're in the business of
representing great athletes so yes their
their athletic talents are foundational
to the partnership
but it is a partnership not a
transaction and
sports are unpredictable if something
doesn't work out
that doesn't mean we're gonna stop
picking up the phone um and so
and the idea is that what we're trying
to do and what we're trying to
incorporate is that
the best time to network as a pro
athlete
is when you're playing the biggest
mistake that former players have made
and i've had numerous conversations like
that is that
they assumed that they could get to the
business stuff
when they were done but the problem is
when they're done
depending on how their career went um
they're just not as relevant as they
once were
and gary and i talked about it like gary
before vaynersports existed would clear
his calendar
if a new york jet or a new york knick
said hey i want to come sit down with
you talk shop
but if they were three or four years
removed
like it's kind of like what have you
done for me lately kind of thing and not
that gary would ignore them but
he just wasn't as excited to take that
meeting and that's the reality of it and
so
we we always tell our guys we encourage
our guys that yes you know you have a
lot on your plate
but if you just got drafted you're hot
right now we can't and yes we believe
you have a great career but we can't
predict that you might shatter an ankle
you might
something may happen right and so um
we're always encouraging our team to be
active and network and
increase their exposure to things while
they play so that when they're done
playing they can really go full steam
ahead and not have to start from scratch
how much of the kind of sophistication
that you guys have
on the business side ends up actually
informing or changing the way that you
negotiate
contracts so for example for an athlete
that says hey i'm going to make 100
this year right and 20 if it's going to
come from my contract but 80 of it's
going to come from endorsement deals and
businesses and investments and other
things
does that actually impact at all the way
that you negotiate the player contract
or those two things
separate and you just kind of have a
holistic plan you know
it's a little bit separate um primarily
because there's
just all these rules and regulations
that dictate
what can and can't be done from a player
contract so
i think that yes we can borrow from our
business experience and things of that
nature but
um i will say that the collective
bargaining agreement um
limits you know some things that we can
and can't do
and that goes sport by sport got it
that's fair um
and i don't know if you maybe you don't
want to name names or something but
maybe give like an example of
uh when you guys talk about what you do
with the athletes
outside of those player contracts like
what's an example whether it's through
an endorsement deal
an investment a business just to give
people a sense of like
hey this is what some of these athletes
are actually doing off of the field
while they're playing
yeah i'll give you an example a recent
one
or relatively recent but i think it's
perfect and speaks to just our approach
uh we represent a guy named derek morgan
derek
um had a great nfl career we represented
him for his last two years in the league
played nine years was with one agency
first switched to another and then
landed with us
and um by the time we started working
with derek he was really
established you know he did really well
he was a former first round pick he
signed a nice second contract
and you know years eight and nine
were kind of accelerating the idea like
he had already started kind of exposing
himself to more he got his mba
as part of a program that miami offered
he did had done some private investing
um and then you know that kind of made
itself selecting why we were such a good
match for one another
um but you know i think him partnering
with us was yeah maybe i'll do one final
contract maybe i won't
let me ramp up while i'm playing and
still active to get a few things going
and so one of the things that um i'm
proud of
is uh first and foremost derek and his
family
are vegan so derek's vegan his wife
charity is actually a chef and vegan
herself they raise their kids vegan
and so one of the things that we helped
to do was um
you know charity is this amazingly
talented and amazingly charismatic
individual
with a real work ethic and she was ready
to kind of now that the kids were
getting a little bit older and derek's
career was kind of settling in
she wanted to take the bull by the horns
and build a personal brand around her
her cooking and and her vegan lifestyle
and so we helped charity launch
her uh personal brand you know designed
her logo built her website got her up on
instagram
walked through content creation
strategies this and the other thing and
charity has done extremely well and you
know we helped her get it started but
she really ran with it and saw the
opportunity
um and then derek um you know
when looking for endorsements we really
doubled down on
who he was you know he said listen
i've done well playing football of
course
getting a 5 10 15 000 endorsement deal
nobody's going to turn that down per se
but the same token i have the luxury of
kind of picking and choosing what i do
based on my own
beliefs and values so one guidance he
gave me and i'll never forget it was
like
i will never endorse something that i
wouldn't from a food perspective
that i wouldn't let my kids eat so if a
company came
and he wouldn't feed that brand to his
kids he's not taking their ten thousand
dollar easy check for an instagram post
so i took that to heart and um you know
through
a network that the morgans had through a
network that we had
uh we circled beyond meat as a perfect
opportunity
for both derrick and charity and so we
did a deal there
um it was not a cash endorsement it was
an equity-based endorsement over a
period of time
and i think where that really worked out
well was you know i sat in the driver's
seat with them negotiating the paperwork
and i think our my experience
and the lawyer that um gary and i use
for all our venture capital related
activity who supported me in this
negotiation on behalf of the morgans
all that experience and gary doing
personal uh advisory type deals
deals with startups where they use his
brand image and likeness and things like
that
i think i don't think there was anybody
more qualified to get the morgans the
best negotiated
advisory equity barter type deal for
a brand like beyond me than us and um
you know the best part was
beyond meat continued being successful
they eventually ipo'd
um and the morgans did a lot better
taking equity as opposed to a small cash
deal there
and i actually remember when i think
he's with the tennessee titans like at
one point
uh his wife by accident i think had
convinced like half the defense
right they were basically eating you
know vegan uh
and there was articles literally written
about the fact that uh you know
here's one of the biggest baddest
meanest defenses in the nfl and
you know nobody's eating any meat you're
exactly right yeah uh
it started because charity was uh
basically meal prepping for derrick
because derek would go to the facility
and a lot of the food there just wasn't
what he was trying to eat and so
he had this food and then one of his
teammates was like hey that looks really
good like can charity maybe hook me up
one of those
he tried it he loved it i think he ended
up being 11 of the 53 titans primarily
on the defense
were vegan for that season two two three
years ago that's
20 of the team vegan it was crazy it was
pretty cool
yeah that's awesome and then uh you're
uh you're understating the performance
of beyond meat it was uh
it absolutely exploded and invaluable
ipo like one of the best ipos of the
year that year right
yeah absolutely um talk a little bit
about the impact of uh of covet
obviously there's certain sports that
uh have kind of been postponed or shut
down
in the middle um obviously we'll see
kind of what happens with the nfl and
their plans to get this going but just
how have you guys seen
the athletes specifically or some of the
contract negotiations impacted by this
it's been a very very unique year um
you know i think that the biggest thing
that kova did to the nfl you know the
nfl was lucky
they were not like the nba or mlb or
these other sports that were in the
season
and how to shut it down you know it was
the off season for the nfl and yes
you know the some of the pre-draft
process was different you know there was
less
in-person meetings things like that that
was an impact
the nfl draft was virtual that was
different
um but as far as like material changes
the nfl really only started experiencing
those material changes over the last few
weeks once training camp got up and
running
um and so it's been different for all
the
obvious um tangible reasons and you know
i think hard knocks
uh the hbo show that's following the
rams and the charges right now
does a really great job kind of showing
how different the nfl is right now with
coven in terms of protocols
around kovid i would say probably the
single biggest
impact that it'll have though on our
clients and the majority of players
is the fact that the preseason was
eliminated it really
reduced the opportunity for rookies
to get up to speed um so i think
the fact that there was no preseason and
that all players weren't
afforded the ability to create uh tape
basically you know go on the field and
do what they can do in a pre-season game
has really um hurt some of the younger
players that need
the opportunity to get on the field and
show what they can do and then on the
flip side i think for veteran players
it's benefited them in that regard
because
you know there's less basically the nfl
it's a next man up type business and
every year there's a new pool of players
trying to take your job
and so if you're an established player
um you know
it's really hard for a younger player to
take your spot
and so i think mostly it's hurt the
young and the unproven
and has helped in terms of security for
some of the more established players
and then i think you'll see i think
especially in the early part of the year
these first few weeks of football games
will be sloppy because the first
few preseason games are sloppy right and
so i think you're going to see a lower
quality football at the outset
but i think you know come mid season
everybody's going to hit their typical
form and
as long as the nfl continues the success
that they've had i think there's only
four active cases in the entire nfl
right now
um as long as they're able to keep it at
bay
i think the season will happen and it'll
be unique that's for sure
yeah i actually didn't notice one of my
brothers was telling me uh at one point
there was this like clause
where uh i think it was any player that
opted out of the season could get
150 000 stipend and you know maybe i'm
off on the number or whatever
but but the whole idea was basically you
know if you're a rookie
and normally you would go to training
camp and maybe you're kind of on the
cusp of will you make the team or get
cut or
you know whatever uh it actually may be
more financially savvy to take the money
right and then kind of live to fight
another day um and
i did maybe 15 minutes of googling and
it seemed like
there was a whole bunch of controversy
around should players do that should
they not how do you think about it
whatever
and it just really highlighted like the
nuances here right is because
somebody's hitting your seat like it
just is more complexity of decision
making it sounds like
absolutely no there was a ton of nuance
um if you look though
i think it was just shy of 70 players
that opted out
and the vast majority were veterans um
and i think if you look at the common
thread we had a client opt out
our client geronimo allison wide
receiver for the lions
um if you look at the most common thread
of the opt out so there's two fat
aspects one uh one point all addresses
and
it's a misconception uh it's not a
stipend
it's actually a cash advance against
your salary and so that so for example
for my client geronimo he got 150 000
the number was right
but it's an advance on his contract he
signed a one-year contract a little over
a million dollars
so if he comes back and plays next year
and he earns that contract he's actually
going to be paid 150 000
less than he was scheduled to earn so
it's in advance
um but uh the other piece too is that if
you were deemed high risk
so if you personally or a significant
other or a child in your house
was high risk from covenant you know
certain aspects of your health history
uh you got 350 instead of 150 000 and if
you look at the breakdown of i think it
was 68 or 69 players that opted out
a good chunk were high risk and then the
next most common thread
was um young family so many players
opted out my client included
had just welcomed a new baby a month
two months three months prior and so
that
that comprised the lion's share of the
players that opted out and for the most
part maybe there was one or two guys
that did it
um but that concept of hey if you're a
football player that probably won't make
the team it's pretty financially savvy
to take 150k
that barely happened and i think the
biggest reason for that is
you have to keep in mind for everybody
coming into the league this is their
dream
and they are on an nfl roster and they
have the ability to make a career out of
this
and you don't get to that point without
believing in your own skill set
and to be a player that sits in that
position maybe you're
on the bottom of the roster if you then
in turn
opt out no nfl team's gonna admit this
but it's a like i said it's a young
there's going to be a new wave of
players next year
and you've dramatically decreased your
opportunity to make a team and so
it was a i i barely anybody took that
round maybe a few
yeah well everyone nobody believes
they're going to get cut either right
that's the whole other you need that
belief and that's and
you know people people like to throw
around the term that this player stinks
or sucks right
the end of the day if you're wearing an
nfl helmet you are an
unbelievable athlete and you're an
unbelievable football player
you just might not be as good you might
just not be one of the
1500 best in the entire world but if
you're the 1600th best football player
in the world
you were the best player in middle
school you were the best player in high
school you were the best players in
college you know what i mean and so
it's so hard for anybody to really
believe in that i wouldn't want anybody
to think of it that way
yeah uh i i love when uh people look at
mma or ufc fights right and they're
basically like oh that guy's horrible
i'm like that guy will literally put
your head through the wall
right there you know
we recently got into the mma business we
represent about 20 fighters
i i've got to spend some time in person
with one or two of them
there's not a single person that walks
into the octagon
that wouldn't send me straight to the
hospital in less than a minute
yeah and and so talk a little bit about
um you guys have
gotten into mma you've gotten uh into
baseball and
also uh gaming talk a little bit about
starting in
nfl and football and then kind of
expanding into those other sports and
kind of why the desire to do that and
then how you guys have actually executed
yeah um always wanted to be a
multi-sport agency
um i think that a strength that i have
is the ability to multitask and do a lot
of different things and
i think our offering what i described
earlier in our conversation applies to
any athlete right and so the ability to
share that offering with multiple
athletes is important um for us we've
been in a great position with you know
the early success that we had on the
football side
my brother's personal brand equity the
brand equity we've been able to build
for vayner sports
we've had so much come our way over the
last few years of hey let's expand into
basketball
baseball cricket soccer everything right
i probably get
five to ten emails a week from somebody
in an industry saying let's expand
um we turned it all down for the first
few years just because we wanted to make
sure
that we made to maintain a focus to
ensure that we
actually delivered on our words right
we we have this belief you know the
conversation you and i had a few years
ago like
we had a plan and a vision but talk is
cheap and we wanted to walk the walk so
we wanted the first few years to make
sure that we
got our offering right and got the flow
right and then over the last year we've
been more open-minded to expanding
um and really our expansion is driven by
opportunity more than anything i've
always said when people ask me
what's going to drive you to expand i
need one of two things
i either need the right partner and what
i mean by that
is somebody who is an established agent
in that business
that has a track record and an
understanding and the relationships
needed to go
do well right away or i needed a marquee
client
so that we could build around that
marquee client and then build the
business
um off the great work that we do there
and the case studies and the reputation
and so for the three sports
uh we brought on uh greg gensky we
merged with his company
greg and his team have an amazing track
record
decades of experience in baseball um
bragg has negotiated four billion
dollars worth of baseball contracts
he's done record-setting deals for guys
like cece sabathia
vernon wells carl crawford all
record-setting
deals all hundred plus million dollar
deals at the time of signing
so walks the walk understands how to
land great players and um
and really saw an opportunity and
synergy between his company and ours
so that checked the box in terms of
finding the right partner for baseball
same thing with mma we brought on an
agent and his team
lloyd pearson lloyd represents hall of
famers champions
has been in the business a long time has
an even longer background just in terms
of sports and
uh negotiations and so that was a
no-brainer for us to get into mma
uh rather quickly and so checked again
the partner box and then the gaming box
because it's a younger industry you
don't really have the most established
partnership opportunities um but
we were able to bring on uh buga
one of the the fortnite champion so we
were able to bring on a gamer
esports athlete who literally is the
best at what he does and fortnite being
one of the biggest titles
uh in our country and so again wasn't
the marquee partner but it was the
marquee client to build around and we've
been doing some great work
with kyle and his family to get him to
where he needs to be
so uh the people that are not up to
speed on uh
um kind of esports will say what do you
mean that uh there's athletes there's
sponsorships and why you guys calling
the sport they're just sitting there
playing video games like you know
the whole nine yards talk a little bit
about we understand now what you do for
like an nfl player for example
what are you guys doing on the on the
esports side and what's the same or
different just given kind of it's uh
yeah much more marketable if you will
and kind of more of an international
appeal
yep so i think the most analogous
example for kyle aka buga
is a golfer or a tennis player right
it's an individual sport
and so we're not actually negotiating
anything from like a team perspective so
to speak right
uh meaning he does not play for the new
york giants he does not play for the
texas rangers
he goes in similar to a golf tournament
um
where he goes in and if there's a cash
prize like the fortnite world cup and he
wins that cash prize he gets that money
we're not negotiating with epic
games or you know twitch or anything
like that in terms of his performance
where the representation comes just like
tennis and golf is on the marketing side
and the opportunities there
so where we're representing kyle is
essentially
the opportunities that he has with
brands and brands direct
and so it's you know i think anybody
that says um
an esports athlete isn't a real athlete
you know
i have empathy for that argument but at
the same token um
in my eyes it's just the modernization
of sports and i think there's a lot of
things that
people in our generation accept as sport
that maybe a hundred years ago
people weren't seeing a sport and humans
evolved and things evolved and
you know at the end of the day it
requires a skill set and talent it
requires a lot of hard work and practice
and he goes and competes against other
people and and wins and there's
something to win
right and if there's uh brands that want
to give the winner a bunch of money
sounds like a sport to me and so um yeah
that's
that's it the easiest really easiest way
to explain is it's just like being a
golfer or tennis player in terms of
being an esports athlete
it makes a lot of sense where do you
guys go with this right see so obviously
this started out as kind of a personal
passion of yours
turned into okay we've got one sport got
a couple of athletes oh wait this works
now you're in multiple sports growing
you know merging with other companies
and agents
and kind of you can see like okay this
is something that is very scalable
across sports
and also kind of vertically you can go
very deep in certain sports
like how do you see this playing out or
what's kind of the vision in your mind
in terms of where you guys are now to
you know ten years from now just more of
the same honestly i think that um
you know probably the most interesting
aspect of it is just
understanding how it best fits within
the entire vayner
ecosystem just because between vayner x
having all sorts of differentiated
offerings and all the different things
that my brother does
um you know vaynersports i think will
continue to
add great clients add more sports
add great groundbreaking you know
marketing endorsements and deals
i think where it probably grows the most
and just
honestly it's only a matter of time
there's nothing that we can do to
accelerate it is just be patient
is what we talked about earlier in terms
of building these deep deep partnerships
with our clients so that they are
you know it'd be amazing if we could
have clients that are more successful
in their post career than their actual
playing career and so i think again
you know i can't have and nor does he
want to nor do i want him to have alan
robinson retire right now
but i know the zoom meetings and the
things that we talked about this off
season
he's going to be able to put into
practice
whenever he's done playing the game of
football and i think the more
we're able to accomplish that and really
show that we're partners
and we're partners for during and post
career
um i think probably what is maybe the
most natural evolution is spin-off
businesses we're actually like
where i'm actually business partners
with alan on a startup together
right you talked about these these
athletes wanting to maybe
instead of just being an investor own
and operate their own i think
plenty of our our clients will own and
operate on their own and i think there
will be situations where
it's interesting enough and we want to
do it with them you know for example uh
derek has a fund uh focus
on opportunity zones and i'm an advisor
of that fund um so i think that will
naturally happen and so
more sports more clients and more
post-career opportunities together yeah
one of the things from the outside um
i think just your entire family right
from your father your brother to
yourself
is you guys always seem to uh kind of
understand okay here's where the world
is
going whether we're right or not we've
got an opinion and
position ourselves there uh and then you
throw yourself
into the mix right and you guys are have
been at least historically very good at
understanding opportunities vetting
those opportunities and choosing when to
uh kind of hey let me spend my time
versus let me spend capital versus let
me just
avoid this right and not spend time and
energy and money um
talk a little bit about have you honed
that over time like
if you don't think of that as a skill
but i actually think that the
when do i actually participate versus
not participate
like that vetting process is uh
probably one of the most important
things you actually do right
that's a great question and i love that
and it's so true i think part of it
part of the answer is um
not having a fear of being perfect i
think what holds people back too
often is they're too worried about the
scoreboard
or what it means or what it what if
they're too early what if they're wrong
you know the way gary and i always
describe it because we talk about this
topic a lot
is we look at that type of activity
as a net score so if you're
right 11 times and you're wrong once
no reason to harp on the one time you
were wrong you're up 10
on the net right and so that's how we
look at it and i think part of why we're
able to
on the outside appear to do so well is
that we're willing to be wrong
we're willing to test we're willing to
iterate and i think maybe even the most
the like the subset skill that's most
important to make the overall skill work
great
is removing your ego and knowing when to
cut bait knowing when to
um i'll give you a good example
anybody that's following my brother
right now now knows he's obsessed with
sports cards
right and so right now there's a real
time and a place where
uh sports cards and collectibles and
things like that
um are having a moment and who knows how
long that moment is that's another skill
um but we've like you said we've thrown
ourselves into it so my brother's credit
him more than i but i've also kind of
followed suit and have been in it pretty
heavy too and
we've put a lot of you know money and
time and effort behind
this concept but what what people don't
realize
is that we actually did this exact same
thing
like seven or eight years ago and failed
we actually started a company called
vaynertoys
nobody knows but it was incorporated we
had staff
and the whole foundational concept was
to buy and sell
vintage toys video games sports cards
collectibles etc
we missed you know our our overhead was
too high
the liquidity of obtaining um
you know the inventory was too illiquid
it just didn't work
um and it didn't have a moment it didn't
you know people didn't suddenly become
obsessed with that type of
uh that type of inventory right and so
we missed but we we cut late quick
we never even really made it very public
um because we knew it was experimental
and we wanted to see
how much it worked or didn't work and so
we missed
but our learnings from that miss allowed
us to really strike and strike hard
this time around and we're doing really
well as of this moment so like i said
the real skill that we need to finish
this piece off is knowing
you know what's the top what's the
bottom more like a stock market type
play here
um but i think we have we had i mean
vaynerx
has all these different divisions that
do so well but we have a lot of
divisions that are in the graveyard
we had a sampling division um
we actually started a co-working space
and we started
we were moving offices so fast we were
growing and we always
were conservative because we said to
ourselves that if we outgrow this office
before our lease is done
we had we this is a champagne problem
having this lease right and
on the flip side if we over extend
ourselves too big of a lease
and we don't do as well we'll get
crushed financially by over
uh pursuing our lease so we've moved
like in new york we moved
like five times in six years or
something because we're just going so
fast which was great
one of those times we did we had like
three years left on the lease we're like
man like this is really just sitting
there um
we actually created something called
vaynerspace
and we tried subleasing that space
and we actually had some good success
and we had tenants sign up but then
eventually the landlord shut us down
um because that they they actually had
another space in the building
that wasn't a co-working space but was
more like a traditional
shared office space and they had a line
in their contract that said that no
other
um company in that building could
compete with them
they told the landlord they shut us down
we took the l right
but constantly willing to try queen
constantly willing to innovate and like
i think the key thing that you said is
like
we're never halfway in or out like we're
passionate we have conviction
we have confidence and we maintain the
same level of confidence
no matter what the end result is if
we're right that confidence helps us be
super successful
if we're wrong we were wrong and we just
deal with it take our l and move on
yeah and i think part of this is um
betting on the right markets obviously
right so understanding hey
you know it's having a moment or scone
to have a moment uh which you guys have
done very well at
but also the execution so it's easy for
kind of armchair quarterback to sit and
say like oh i think sport
sports cards are gonna be big in three
years uh and i've got some money
but what do i do right or i've got some
time and energy and
and i'm intrigued but what do i do both
you and gary have been
great operators and so for you like how
have you
grown from a management perspective from
an operator standpoint
and you know i'm assuming that now you
deal with different problems but you're
able to go from kind of
zero to 50 right and it's more muscle
memory in
this new industry rather than having to
start all over again and
kind of start from scratch yeah i think
that um
i love this question too um i
i've had a lot of thoughts around this
concept and it's an opportunity to kind
of articulate it and
we'll see how i do um i think our
society
utilizes the term experience in a very
narrow-minded way
and in a very traditional way that i
don't think is actually the right
reflection of experience i don't think
we're counting
experience correctly so the way
experience is predominantly defined
in sports in business in just about
anything is years
right if you've been doing something for
20 years you
probably have more experience and you're
probably better at what you do than
somebody that has five years experience
i completely disagree my mindset is to
your point you know the things that i
deal with operating we're a small
company we're about 20 people
but things pop up i'm dealing with
different problems my ability to work
quickly and efficiently and do those
things well come from the fact that
i don't think i have 11 would have
11 years of business experience i truly
feel like i have like 80
because in 2011
we went from 150 to 400 employees you
can't tell me that that year of
experience counts the same as somebody
else's year of experience doing
far less right and so it's kind of like
there has to be something to be said
about talent um
repetition practice opportunities to
implement those out you know like
malcolm gladwell's ten thousand hours i
think it's a cousin of that
and and what i always try to tell people
you know because something that i face
is that
you know if i'm walking in and
recruiting a young athlete um
that's a question that comes up you know
i've only been in the football i've been
only an athlete rep for like four years
i've been in business for 11. i'm 33.
um you know how how can
how can i make somebody feel comfortable
how can i make the kid
or their family feel comfortable that
they're in the right hands with me
and part of it's like i try to use like
sports like i love carmelo anthony right
carmel is a great great player hall of
famer
right but tomorrow you have to start an
nba friendship franchise
you want luca or you want everybody's
going to say luca
right and my point is that
just because and that's not a perfect
analogy but my point is just because
somebody has 20 years of experience of
doing something
doesn't mean they actually have the true
authentic experience of doing the things
that you need them to do on your behalf
and i feel as if my my
years of experience far outweigh the
actual 11 years that it is
my father once said to me and it just
was like seared in my brain he said
some people get 10 years of experience
and some people get
two years of experience five times right
which was just like you know some people
are hey i've done this for 10 years
but really you only learn things for the
first two years
and you just repeated it over and over
again until you got to a 10-year mark
and you somehow think that
that is 10 years of experience it's
really not right and i think that's kind
of your your point here is
exactly right and it also feels like the
skills
that i think a lot about like a uh a
tool kit that an operator has right and
there's like core skills so
you have to be able to communicate you
gotta be able to hire well you gotta be
able to manage like all that kind of
stuff
but then there's the like outside of
that core skill set
very industry specific things so the
ability to negotiate with a professional
sports team a contract is a skill set
that is specific to
the sports industry right there's nobody
else in the world who is going
into work every day and trying to do
that stuff yeah and so
where do you think about mentorship
versus just kind of trial by fire
and what i mean by that is there's
obviously a lot of people who have done
the business that you're in today uh for
a long time so they've got
some value just because they've
literally survived right let alone
thrive
uh and then some of it's just you got to
learn on your own right and you want to
do things differently so how do you kind
of
find that balance between taking stuff
from the
the core skill set of people who've been
around for a long time versus
hey we want to do something different we
think that's actually where the
innovation and disruption comes from
yeah so i'm a big advocate and a big
believer
of having somebody with experience and
traditional experience
in the industry that you're attacking so
for example with vaynermedia
we brought in a gentleman named james
orsini
and james came in um and eventually
replaced me as ceo we hired him with the
idea that he would replace me but it was
about a year after we hired him
and what we liked about bringing on
james uh in particular and we had other
people prior
is we he was like our chief context
officer and so so many meetings were had
as we were building this rocket ship of
a media agency where it was like all
right james how would this
because he had big big traditional
holding company massive agency
experience
james this is a situation how would they
handle it
he would explain it and would say it
would either be okay we should learn
from that and take like 90
of that and make it our own and like do
that or cool we're definitely not
[ __ ] doing that that's terrible
right and so he literally was there and
so many other
uh partners and employees prior to that
just to inform us
and again because you don't want to
recreate the wheel right and so
there's definitely things we did in the
first two to three years of vaynermedia
that was a waste of time and we
recreated the wheel for no reason
um but having somebody basically tell
you the context
and then we're able to make our own
informed decision based on that
um i think is massively helpful and so
same thing with vaynersports
um one member of our team in particular
andrew brandt
is basically my chief context officer in
this regard he's somebody that
um started his career as an agent he
actually worked for um
david falk one of the legendary
basketball agents who have jordan and
ewing amongst others
and so andrew worked for falk uh for a
number of years then he actually got
poached by the green bay packers to go
run
uh their football administration salary
cap for the packers for about 10 years
and then he actually after that went
into the world of media so he appears on
espn he writes for
uh sports illustrated and a few other
things right so he's got this
three different aspects of the industry
experience
and so he is a member of vaynersports
he's a certified agent for us again we
brought him out of retirement as an
agent
um but his biggest role is like that
chief context officer perspective and
what i love about him is he can tell me
how
a big agent would do it he also tells me
what the team is thinking
because he served he's the most senior
team executive that is currently a
sports
agent uh on the football side now and so
his biggest value that he brings to me
is context and information and then i do
with that what i think is best
yeah that's awesome uh when this is all
over what do you want people to remember
you for
i think the biggest thing that i want to
be remembered for
is making an impact and doing it the
right way
so i want to be remembered as somebody
that um
that really helped people be successful
and and didn't cut corners or didn't
screw anybody over along the way um you
know there's somebody one of my business
partners is a guy named brandon parker
brandon's father um is the late great
eugene parker
eugene is one of the best football
agents of all time one of the best
sports agents of all time he
unfortunately passed away a little while
ago
um but eugene represented hall of famers
up and down
uh he was deion sanders his agent for
context he was
when uh when you get elected in the pro
football hall of fame you actually
nominate somebody to induct you and they
put the gold jacket on you and
everything dion nominated eugene
and so brandon is now my business
partner he's the chief operating officer
of our football practice
and the single biggest compliment that
i've gotten since being in this industry
has come from brandon it's come from
brandon
maybe five or six times just randomly
we'll be talking through a situation
whether it's a challenge or something
with a client or
an a strategy session we're having and i
was like man like
you remind me so much of my dad and and
it's the biggest compliment for me
because being business partners with
brandon
um and running into people in the
industry
i've never met a single person that
hasn't said the most glowing things
about the late great eugene parker
and and the theme is he was the best
and he did it in the best way and so i
guess that's i'll summarize it that way
i want to be the best i want to do in
the best way possible
that's absolutely awesome um that's the
same
uh two questions to wrap up and then you
could ask me one two let's
end it uh the first is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
it's a good question i am not a great
great reader it's something i wish i was
better at
what's the most important piece of
content that you've ever considered
could be a movie it could be
whatever you want music whatever you
want that's a good okay
i like that um and i appreciate you
throwing me the life raft
i will say the single best piece of
content i've ever consumed in my life
was one of my brothers um and i think
that fits you know he's my mentor
my best friend my brother older brother
jerry did a post
it's a silly one too um but i think it's
important because it doesn't really have
anything to do with business it doesn't
have anything really to do with anything
tactical it's more just like emotional
and and getting through life in the best
way possible
he used the analogy of a bucket and he
basically said listen
you know to people that are watching
your
your body and your your capacity for
dealing
with adversity or your troubles or your
own personal demons whatever
think of it as a bucket and and the
way to release the water that's filling
up that bucket
is through open and honest communication
and being honest with yourself
and what you want to do is as that
bucket is filling up
you want to let water out the bucket
before it fills up the worst thing that
you can do is have the bucket come to
the tippy top
because that's the breaking point and
that's when you're going to break and so
for me
i think we talked about it earlier i
i was very fortunate and and i'm
self-aware like i said i started on
third base
uh as far as business goes i started on
third base as far as life goes really
you know i grew up
um comfortable my family was middle
class
i by the time i went to college you know
my parents took care of my college
tuition and college day i'm lucky as
[ __ ]
right but on the flip side uh one area
where i got
unlucky was with my personal health um i
suffered from something called crohn's
disease
a disease that has no cure at least yet
um
one that impacts your uh digestive tract
your intestines and your colon and
things of that nature and
i really struggled with my crohn's um
mainly
in my call up from like 18 to 25
um countless trips to the er countless
different types of medication trying to
help it
um i had a period of time like a
three-month period of time where i went
to the doctor to give blood
every single week for three months um
leading up i ended up having intestinal
surgery leading up to that surgery i
went to the er five different times in a
12-month period
and so between dealing with my personal
health issues
and the stress that came with taking a
company from two to six hundred people
over a seven year period of time
i uh i struggled in some ways and i
think that piece of content
really helped me understand how to deal
with my struggles and maintain those
struggles and
and turn those struggles upside down and
so uh
probably the most impactful thing i ever
did and i'm glad to share it
is i sought out therapy i sought to help
um my therapy was
entirely focused it was a very narrow
subject but i think
it helped me um it helped me immensely
and i think it also helped me
um utilize that same kind of thinking
and concept across
other parts of my life it was entirely
centered around my battle
with my health and my career and how
the trickiest part was um one of the
worst things for crohn's disease is
stress
but one of the most stressful things i
would endure
in my career was falling behind because
i got sick
and so now that is a nasty nasty
cyclical pattern right
and so my entire i went to therapy for
like a year and a half or two years
and it was entirely centered around that
basically working through
coming to grip with my health and coming
to grip with my career
and and finding a path towards allowing
those two things to exist with one
another
and so um i think my brother's piece of
content was the tip of the iceberg
for basically um because i think
what i struggled with was i internalized
everything it was two things one
grew up in a very competitive family and
had a lot of pride
and i guess ego to be successful and do
well and not show that weakness
but then also i felt like and i still
believe this to an extent that a leader
within a company needs to display
strength right and so if i was a mess
walking in as the ceo of a fast-growing
rocket ship type company
that would hurt the business right and
so i just really struggled with
the balance of of dealing with it all
and i think my brother's content
um i actually don't watch a lot of my
brother's stuff it's kind of a joke
people
like i out of all the content my
brother's ever created i've probably
seen like one to two percent of it
um i i don't think i've seen a single
piece of my brother's content in months
and the point i make is that not that i
don't love that content
i love my brother's content i'm just
blessed that i get to experience it just
because i speak to him on the phone or
do business like i don't need to rewatch
it basically
but that was one random piece i saw that
helped and i think that was pretty
significant for me because
it impacted my my career it impacted my
relationship with my family
my friends everything how much of its
importance do you think was it that gary
wrote it versus
could have been anybody else like do you
think that made you pay more attention
to it yeah
i think i was fascinated fascinated by
the fact that like
people we know we tend to internalize
the content more
right i think it definitely played a
role that was gary um
you know i think you gotta take into
account 11 years older than i am and so
growing up when i'm 5 or 6 he's 17 16 17
right he goes to college when i'm seven
right he's
he's in in orders of magnitude older
than me at that point right he's almost
triple my age and so
i think that you know i always looked up
to him both physically and well i don't
look up to him anymore taller than him
but you know throughout my childhood
always looked up to him physically
and and metaphorically and then you know
up until that point
i had so much um
i had so much success before i watched
that video right i'm 24
25 doing really well the interview is
doing so well
everything i did up until that point a
lot of it was lent from just following
my brother's kind of mentorship and
guidance so i think because of that
he had a ton of credibility for me and
it resonated
uh as the oldest of uh five boys
there was zero chance we were getting
out of this conversation without
one jab being thrown in and so it was it
was subtle but if you didn't catch that
aj said he's taller than gary
that one's out of his control
but the other jab that i'll give is that
i like to throw
at him is um he can't be president at
least he can't be now he wasn't born
here
so i think my brother can do anything
but that one legally isn't within his
hands
i love it i uh i i don't think that i
could go through a conversation
listening to my brother's uh without
them throwing jabs so that's uh that's
fair
game he can't control either one of
those so perfect
that's right exactly uh second question
that you'll get to ask me one to finish
is a little bit more fun
aliens believer or non-believer
believer why um not not based anything
on anything tangible not because i saw a
ufo or i believe
any of those things but my mindset is
just that like
if if we're on planet earth and we're
all doing this thing
and there's all these other planets that
we know for sure exist
and then there's this just unbelievably
vast
area that we don't know anything about
even though it's been thousands of years
of us researching and we have the best
brightest minds in the world working on
it
i'm more so just playing the odds of
just like they're just i just feel like
there has to be something else going on
that's really it again like i'm not i
don't have any theories
i haven't seen a ufo i don't really
believe most of the ufo stories that i
hear but it just feels like how can like
it feels it feels a little self-centered
and egotistical to think that we're the
only thing living and breathing and
making [ __ ] happen around
it feels like every once in a while
there's like one of these scientific
i'll call it a breakthrough basically
like a discovery right like i don't know
there was ice on mars or you know
whatever the thing is that previously
was thought to not be the case
and there's a lot of people are like
freaking out and there's this group of
people who are just like
well if did you think we knew everything
right right you know
like it's kind of just like you know
even earth right i mean they discover
things all the time in the ocean or
whatever
and you're just like look we probably
know way less than we're comfortable
understanding so i think
i think that's probably the foundation
of my saying yes that i just feel like
you just made that point like there just
has to be more
that's kind of how i feel and we're
there's so much we haven't figured out
that it makes me feel like
that makes it pretty obvious that there
is something else going on absolutely
uh you could ask me one question to uh
finish up what you got for me well
as the oldest brother um
do you name a do you have a pivotal
point in your life
where you felt as if you really had to
step out
up to the plate for one of your younger
brothers and if you're comfortable
sharing like
you don't have to go into detail i don't
want anything too personal like
situations where the oldest had a really
you know i feel like my brother shaped
so much for me and was there for me
i'd love to hear it from your you know
your experience on the other side of the
table
so i'm going to tell you a story that i
didn't
and in hindsight my parents basically
like you know beat it into my head of
like hey
this is your job type situation uh i
think i was in uh
third grade my brother was in first
grade we're on the school bus
and they just played this stupid game i
literally think it was called like slap
jacks or something where the kid in the
seat in front would turn around and they
would you know basically slap each
other's hands on the top of the
scene and uh i can't remember if i was
sitting next to my brother or near my
brother or whatever
but next thing i know i see his face and
you know he's in pain
not crying but like something's wrong
and i basically said you know
are you good yeah he's fine right as a
uh as a first grader who doesn't want to
get in trouble you know kind of does
and he's holding his hand but he didn't
really want to show it to me whatever so
we go to school the whole day and i kind
of forget about it we go home and
he basically uh walks in the door and he
shows my mom is
his hand and i can't you know i mean
literally one of his fingers is
uh one of the joints is off it's like a
45 degree ink like i mean it's just
it's broken you don't have to be a
doctor like hey we got to get this taken
care of
uh and in hindsight you know it's kind
of all these things like how did a first
grader go the entire day at school
and like it was tough you know
but but i remember when uh when he
showed my mom my mom's
first reaction when she goes how did
this happen and he said on the school
bus
and she immediately turned and looked at
me and said what did you do yeah
and i remember being like what do you
mean and she was like somebody hurt your
brother and you didn't do anything
it was the first time i realized like oh
wait a second like that rule about like
you know no fighting
that only applies if you know it's it's
somebody other than your brother type
situation right like hey
you're supposed to do certain things to
protect your brothers or whatever
and so it was this like weird situation
where
you know i i wasn't in very many
situations you know
from like a physical danger standpoint
but i think that just like that moment
was uh one in which you realize like
this applies not
just to their physical safety but a
whole bunch of other areas yeah and
i i've talked to my mom about it before
i'm like i probably wouldn't have
learned that so much later in life
unless
in that moment she didn't yell at my
brother she like the first thing she did
was she turned and she said it to me
i remember being like wait a second
you're telling me he broke his finger
and i'm about to get in trouble
like i love that though your mom killed
it and that
i love that story and it speaks to the
big picture of things
that's a good one i love that yeah and
the other thing too is so you've got one
brother one sister right
so uh in a family of five boys we fought
all the time
right over you know stupid stuff
everything from you're wearing my socks
to
you know i'm gonna eat the last cookie
type situation and uh my dad used to
tell us all the time he's like look
whatever you guys do in here i don't
want you guys fighting or anything right
but like what you're going to do what
you're going to do in basically i'm
going to try to you know make sure
nobody gets hurt
uh but when you walk outside nobody can
mess with
your brothers like you can right and so
it's always like this this weird thing
and
um i'm between me and my youngest
brother uh eight years different so
you know close to you yeah yeah and so
when i
when you think about that like that's a
pretty big difference right 11 years
eight years like
you know when i was in middle school my
brother's like not even in school yet
right and and so you just like that i
think is the hard part is the age
difference but then once you get past a
certain age and
you know maybe 20 like the youngest one
then it's like hey look we're
all together right yeah maybe somebody's
got more experience than whatever but at
this point it's
you know the the age difference matters
less i think absolutely i agree with
that completely i think
something that i've really been enjoying
um is being a father
i have a uh a three-year-old daughter a
one-and-a-half-year-old son and a third
on the way in december
oh wow yeah like are you excited super
excited super nervous honestly because
we're gonna have three kids under three
and a half
that's going to be a thing are you ready
for that
oh yeah i sure am i mean what else am i
gonna say right
um but what's been cool though is you
know for me
i was the youngest in my family and even
within cousins there was never
a cousin that was young enough or close
enough to like
for me to impart some of this stuff and
you know i've enjoyed mentoring
um you know younger uh young
professionals and things like that but
like teaching my daughter life lessons
along the way based
on like [ __ ] you just described for
example i've really
um taken that responsibility to heart
and i think it's because of like what my
parents did and what my siblings did for
me as the youngest is now my turn
um so it's been i love that story with
your mom and your brother
yeah that's awesome uh i've got to
imagine that your son and your daughter
even though they don't realize it yet
like just being so close in the age
later on in life going oh this is pretty
cool right yeah yeah not right now
they're they're fighting a lot
um but for sure and it was something you
know my wife
is less than two years younger than her
brother and i look at their relationship
and
my relationship with my sister and my
brother is as close as possible like we
are
uncomfortably ridiculously close best
friends
but i i and they know i was by myself
from 10 to 18. you know my by the time i
was 10
both my brother and sister were in
college and so i think like man wouldn't
it be cool to go to middle school with
them or go to high school with them and
i didn't have that and they did
they were my brother was a senior my
sister was a freshman in high school so
they had that one year like that kind of
thing and
they shared friends growing up and
things like that i was in completely
different
uh generations so to speak so i'm very
excited for
our three kids to literally be it'll end
up being i think senior high school
sophomore high school eighth grader for
r3 which is pretty dope
yeah that's awesome where uh where can
we send people to find you on the
internet or
uh anything about vintage sports yeah uh
for me personally twitter and instagram
it's just ajv those three initials my
initials um
and then same thing primarily twitter
and instagram uh just vaynersports
where we're at mostly awesome man
anytime you get a a three
three letter uh handle you know you were
early right it was early that that was
the benefit of having our hands at
silicon valley early for sure
absolutely all right man thank you so
much for doing this aj walked through it
again in the future
appreciate you brother take care